let's go to alex from orange county alex
from orange county are on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
awesome so
um i remember you said every
midterm election if the if the president
wins the opposing signs
um also when um why do you think that no
no
so that's that's not always the case but
that's it's often the case
not always okay um
is there a reason why that happens do
people just stay home and assume oh
we're all good or something like that
yeah i think it's a combination of
things so i think
when when you have one party win a
presidential election
um and then you have a midterm two years
later there's a couple different things
that are going on one
in general there's a lower turnout in
midterms than there is in presidential
elections so by its very nature that
means that
uh whoever is more motivated in the
midterm has a better shot at being able
to turn the election
in their favor and uh what motivates
people to get out and vote well
it's their opponent winning so when you
see one party win in a presidential
it will often be more motivational to
the opponents of that
uh a person to the the members of the
party that is in opposition to the
winner of the white house
and so you'll see them come out in
larger numbers in the following midterms
that's typically the way it goes i don't
know that that's the way 2022 will go
though
um um okay um
can i ask you one more thing of course
um
um after the 2020 elections do you trust
um
poly data at all even though like it
really felt like um
joe biden really had this in the bag but
we were all
pretty nervous you know when election
day happened i mean listen
um the the nat the the the polling data
certainly was skewed more in the biden
direction
than what ended up being the actual
outcome
now joe biden was projected to win the
popular vote
and he did and joe biden was projected
to win the electoral vote and he did but
there's no denying that the margin was
not what many expected it to be
including in states like wisconsin
as an example so you know the
trusting polling data is very black and
white i think we have to understand the
limitations of polling but at the same
time
understand that um uh
it's uh it is not as precise precise as
many of us would want and as i spoke
about with david shore
not long ago he pointed out that the
idea of
we now have such politicization of
polling that there are certain
populations that will respond to polling
in a certain way and that can skew the
results we have to be
we have to account for that that's a
real thing
oh okay well um that'll be all david and
thank you for taking my call
my pleasure great to hear from you
really appreciate it and then why don't
we talk
to uh how about we speak to
antonioni from chicago i hope i'm
pronouncing that correctly
hey can you hear me david yes i can yeah
no
that's that's correct pronunciation love
it um big fan of the show
thanks for taking the call thank you so
much of what i have to ask is about
um covered relief and budget
reconciliation okay
i kind of okay so i guess i need to
refresh a little bit on the current
current status and the next action step
so
right now we're trying to pass covert
relief through budget reconciliation
yes which that passed the house correct
uh yes it did now you know now you have
me doubting where it stands right now
yeah yeah
and i didn't mean to put you on on spot
here because i realized there's so much
going on yeah and there is always a new
update so like if you don't know one of
these questions like i totally get it
yeah no i'm not up to speed as to it i
know that democrats
believe they need to move forward
without republicans and that that
clearly is the case i actually am unsure
where the bill is right now
yeah i don't know if it passed the house
or not because i thought it did and then
there was still debate you know about
the income threshold
that who's going to get the uh you know
the relief indeed so i was like okay
maybe it didn't pass the house
um anyway so i guess what i'm going to
is i really wanted to know your opinion
on do you think
reoccurring relief is even going to be a
thing or is this going to be
one of the i mean if you had a guess i
know it's really hard we're in a
pandemic you don't know
how this is going to play out but we're
seeing how long this process takes and
it's
i guess it's not too long you know it's
expectable it's been a month
like since bidens came into office um
[Music]
but it's for that 1400 and you know and
there's some progressives fighting for
two thousand dollars
recurring and i just don't
like how long is like what's going to be
the process for that because i know we
have to get this 1400
yeah through through budget
reconciliation so what would the process
then be
to get another 2000. yeah you're you're
exactly right uh i
i hate to rain on anybody's parade i
don't think
recurring payments are going to happen
and uh there are people that love the
idea of sort of like pandemic
basic income in a sense um if things
particularly as you're pointing out it's
a lot of work just to get
these fourteen hundred dollars done and
i hope that we we start to recover from
the pandemic
both from a health standpoint and an
economic standpoint
and if that happens uh i don't know i
don't even think
that you're going to have republi
democrats in the senate going for
recurring payments so i i want to be as
real with the audience as i can
i don't see it i don't see it happening
i don't see it either no no i agree
um and and i guess one of the last
questions that
has to still do with this is there's
there's all this talk about you know
there's a lot of democrats
were fighting to lower that threshold to
50k yes um for the relief
do we who who are they because every
joe manchin is kind of like you know the
mascot for them but i don't know who the
other ones are
and i guess they're not they're they're
going anonymous does that
seem to be what the issue is i don't
have the list in front of me but this is
exactly what we were talking about
when joe biden won where we were saying
you know
if we're assuming everything will be 50
50 and then kamala gets it through
we're forgetting that there are
occasionally
democrats who don't just sign their
names to what joe biden wants or to what
the bulk of the democrats in the senate
want and
and we are seeing that yeah i'm again
obviously i just i don't know that it
needs to be said i'm against lowering
the threshold to 50 000.
yeah okay i mean that's it and i um
you know i hope i saw how like kamala
was interviewing with
you know the newspaper where joe manchin
is from or whatever trying to push him
to get that through and i
i hope there's more tactics like that to
push these
um people that are more center to the
left and
this time certainly yeah awesome thanks
so much for taking the call i appreciate
it all right
from chicago great to hear from you uh
we're gonna go to a break sorry i wasn't
able to get to everybody i do my best
but i can never get to everybody
uh there's always more we will take a
quick break and be back with more right
after this